let's say you're playing a party game
ocean trivia and someone asks what is
the world's largest bony fish the answer
is this fish right here
the mola mola or giant sunfish it looks
like a massive swimming head but can
move with surprising speed thanks to its
large fins in its lifetime the mola mola
will grow from 1/10 of an inch long to a
fish that's 14 feet long weighing 4,000
pounds
to put that in perspective a mola mola
can gain over sixty million times its
birth weight you'll find the mola mola
in warm and temperate zones of all
oceans it eats fishes ZOA plankton and
jellyfish and is eaten by sea lions this
mola mola won't make it to 4,000 pounds
but these others these are the living
proof you need to win at trivia contest